however we recognize there are some very
specific circumstances
where there would be a serious risk of
harm to public welfare
if people in critical roles are unable
to go to their workplace
like air traffic controllers or train
signals so people in those kinds of
roles who have received two vaccinations
plus two weeks beyond the second vaccine
will not need to self-isolate perform
those critical
tasks they will however have to continue
to self-isolate
at all other times the people eligible
for this will receive personalized
letters setting out
the steps they must follow mr speaker
this is a
sensible and pragmatic step and one that
will be used
sparingly and responsibly mr speaker we
are being
similarly pragmatic at our borders as my
right honourable friend the transport
secretary
has confirmed uk residents arriving from
amber countries who have been fully
vaccinated will no longer have to
quarantine
although they will still need to comply
with necessary testing requirements
this will not apply to france due to the
persistent presence of cases of the beta
variant which was first identified in
south africa
we're doing everything in our power to
restore international travel
and restore it safely but new variants
pose the greatest threat
to our path out of this pandemic and we
will not hesitate
to act in a similar way with any other
country we will continue to keep a close
eye on the data and be firm and decisive
in how we protect the process we have
made
and the progress we have made but the
enduring message is this mr speaker
getting vaccinated is the best way to
ensure you can travel as freely
as possible vaccination also holds the
key
for doing the things we love here at
home mr speaker
we are supporting the safe reopening of
large crowded settings such as
nightclubs as we saw last night and
music
venues with the use of the nhs covert
pass
as a condition of entry to reduce the
risks of transmission
i encourage businesses to draw on the
support
and use the nhs cobot pass in the weeks
ahead
we will be keeping a close watch on how
it is used by venues
and we reserve the right mr speaker to
mandate if
necessary by the end of september
everyone aged
18 and over will have the chance to
receive full vaccination
and the additional two weeks for that
protection to really take hold
so at that point we plan to make full
vaccination
a condition of entry to nightclubs and
other venues where large crowds
gather proof of a negative test will no
longer be
sufficient any decisions will of course
mr speaker be subject to parliamentary
scrutiny and we will ensure
the appropriate exam exemptions for
those who have genuine medical reasons
of why they can't get vaccinated and i'm
clear we will
always look at the evidence available
and do all we can to ensure people can
continue
to do the things they love mr speaker
our vaccination program has put us
on the road to recovery we should all be
proud of how this national effort is
helping us
take steps towards a more normal life
but we must keep reinforcing
that wall of protection getting the jab
getting the second jab
if you had the first and getting the
booster shot if you're asked to come
forward and with such a deadly virus and
the continued threat of new variants our
wall of protection
must be more than just vaccines alone
we must continue to do all the other
sensible things
we know can keep the virus at bay
getting tested
considering the advice and continuing to
act with caution
taken together mr speaker this will help
us all
enjoy these new experiences and safely
slow
the spread of this deadly virus i
commend the statement to the house